et moi je vais vous parler d'un sujet
très différents mais vous allez voir que
il ya un fil malgré tout et ce fut dit
ça va être celui de l'intérêt à l'autre
puisque je vais vous parler aussi dans
une approche différente mais
probablement complémentaire de l'intérêt
à l'autre je vais donc vous parler de
mécénat de philanthropie c'est des
grands mots je ne suis pas un historien
pourtant le mécénat une longue histoire
derrière lui depuis que monsieur messer
nas gréco-latin l'a créée à rome
il était le parrain ii du poète au vide
je ne suis pas un philosophe non plus et
pourtant le mot de philanthropie est un
mot largement utilisé dans la dans la
philosophie dont je vous précise que ça
veut dire
amour de l'autre dont je suis un
banquier j'ai fait un très vilain métier
pendant 40 ans mais j'ai essayé de me
racheter en m'intéressant à des sujets
d'intérêt général et j'ai découvert le
mécénat à travers la création en 1984 de
la fondation paribas cette banque était
nationalisé à l'époque et son nouveau
patron
avez vous lu que elle fait la
démonstration qu un grand établissement
financier pouvait s'intéresser à autre
chose qu'à gagner bestialement de
l'argent et donc qu'on a créé cette
fondation j'ai eu la chance de
participer à cette aventure depuis le
départ et ça m'a ouvert à beaucoup de
sujet de l'intérêt général
ensuite mon métier ça a été pendant près
de 20 ans la banque privée je
m'intéressais je m'occupais des damnés
de la terre c'est à dire les gens qui
ont de l'argent d' un peu partout dans
le monde et ce métier c'est un métier
qui a beaucoup de charme parce que cet
incendie un people business est un
métier on rencontre des gens des vrais
gens
c'est probablement le seul métier de la
finance où on s'adresse pas à des
professionnels à des patrons du
directeur financier du trésorier mais à
des gens et on leur parle d'un sujet qui
les intéressent leur patrimoine bien sûr
l'argent mais pas que ça aussi leur
passion
ce qu'ils peuvent avoir envie d'investir
dans l'art
dans les forêts dans les vignobles et
puis dans le fil au courant des
pérégrinations parce que dans ce métier
il faut aller voir les gens les
rencontrer parler avec eux si on veut
savoir ce qu'ils attendent
j'ai été de plus en plus interpellé par
une phrase que j'entendais très souvent
j'ai envie de rendre à la société alors
ça s'explique comment très simplement
l'argent il a beaucoup changé dans sa
forme
autrefois être une personne riche
c'était être un vieux monsieur de plus
de 75 ans et qui avait hérité sa fortune
aujourd'hui la personne riche type le
client type d'une banque privée
c'est une personne active entre 50 et 60
ans c'est de plus en plus souvent une
femme et ça change énormément
l'approchent et puis ce sont des gens
qui ont construit leur fortune avec leur
vie professionnelle
alors quand on a hérité on veut
transmettre
j'ai reçu je transmets c'est normal
quand on a construit sa fortune
on a une approche complètement
différente on a une approche
d'entrepreneurs et j'ai constaté que ces
gens qui se retrouvent entre 50 et 60
ans parfois beaucoup plus jeunes parce
que quand on fait fortune dans le net ça
peut être beaucoup plus jeunes quand ils
se retrouvent confrontés si je puis dire
à des sommes d'argent qui peuvent être
parfois absolument colossal eh bien il
ya une espèce d'interrogation
existentielle mais tout ce fric pour
quoi faire
et la réponse qu'on soit chinois latino
américains ou de belfort elle est
toujours la même il ya trois niveaux
d'abord je vais vivre de façon
sympathique à la fin de mes jours parce
qu'après tout je vais bien mérité mes
enfants si j'en ai je vais leur donner
les moyens de construire la vie qui
veulent avoir qui veulent se construire
mais sûrement pas les moyens de rien
faire jusqu'à la fin de leurs jours
et pour le reste et ce reste peut être
parfois considérables eh bien je suis
prêt à leur remettre dans la société à
leur et investir dans la société ce sont
des entrepreneurs ils donnent pas ils
investissent sans bien sûr aucune
considération de retour pour eux-mêmes
mais avec un appétit de retour social
ils veulent que leur argent serve à
quelque chose
le réinvestir dans la société et donc
quand j'ai constaté ça je me suis dit
ben mon métier de banquier privé qui est
un métier de conseil
je peut l'enrichir je peux mettre une
brique supplémentaire
en apportant du conseil en philanthropie
parce que ces gens qui me disaient ça il
ajouté très souvent bah oui mais
investir dans la société c'est compliqué
c'est pas les mêmes méthodes que dans le
business e on sait pas bien vers quoi
aller on a besoin d aide
et donc je me suis dit je peux bâtir
quelque chose je peux je vais pouvoir
apporter un conseil à mes clients pour
les aider à construire leur
philanthropie et les accompagner dans
leur aventure philanthropiques
donc je suis allé voir ma direction
générale et je leur ai dit que j'avais
l'intention de créer ce service là qu'il
fallait que je recrute pour sa des
spécialistes j'ai dit que je souhaitais
que ce service soit gratuit parce que je
considérais qu'il n'y avait pas de
raison qu'on gagne de l'argent quand on
veut travailler pour l'intérêt général
alors bien sûr on m'a regardé un peu de
travers quand on parle de gratuité dans
une banque on vous regarde de travers
mais on va laisser faire et j'ai fait
deux choses complémentaires en dehors du
revêtement de cette équipe j'ai créé une
fondation s'appelle la fondation de
l'orangerie qui avait pour vocation de
servir de réceptacle à l'argent de ses
potentiels philanthrope de ces
philanthropes en herbe donc la banque
n'était pas un centime dedans c'est la
fondation des clients et puis j'ai il me
semblait qu'il était souhaitable de
parler plus de la philanthropie qu'on ne
le faisait j'avais constaté que la
philanthropie elle est extrêmement
visible aux états unis elle est
culturelle les mêmes ça fait partie du
statut social quand on a réussi on et
philanthrope
on le retrouve dans la partie disons
anglo saxon de l'europe on le retrouve
en belgique tout près de chez nous aux
pays bas en allemagne en suisse très
importante
on le retrouve aussi bien sûr en
angleterre en france
pas trop enfin ça se voyait pas parce
qu'en france on est marqué par ce vieux
principe judéo-chrétien le bien ne fait
pas de bruit le bruit ne fait pas de
bien donc qu'il se passait des choses on
faisait des choses il y avait des
grandes familles dont on savait qu'elle
était investi dans la philanthropie mais
on n'en parlait pas et moi j'ai pensé
qu' il y avait un enjeu très important a
parlé de la philanthropie a montré ce
que peut faire la philanthropie pour
qu'elle se développe et donc j'ai
demandé à créer un prix de la
philanthropie et donc depuis 2008 vient
de thé paribas revient en fait deux prix
de la philanthropie un grand prix
qui récompense un grand philanthrope
pour l'ensemble de son oeuvre comme on
dit au festival de cannes avec un
critère d'argent dominante
et puis un prix qu'on appelle coup de
coeur on récompense plutôt
l'investissement des personnes
l'engagement des personnes dans un
projet de caractère philanthropique
alors la flandre puis moi je t'adore en
parler parce que c'est que des belles
histoires et je peux vous dire que
depuis dix ans que je m'intéresse à ça
maintenant depuis trois ans j'ai quitté
mes fonctions je ne fais plus que ça le
mécénat et la philanthropie et bien je
n'ai rencontré que des belles histoires
qu'ils racontent et quelques-unes très
rapidement parmi les vainqueurs de ce
but ce prix que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
la première année on a eu comme comme
vainqueur une femme marocaine qui
s'appelle amina laraki qui se trouve à
être la fin la fille d'un ancien premier
ministre et cette femme a eu un grand
drame dans sa vie alors qu'elle avait
une trentaine d'années elle a eu un
accident de vélo dont elle est resté
paralysé des jambes et elle avait eu une
flamme une énergie formidable
et donc quand elle a revécu après une
longue phase hospitalière elle s'est dit
je peux pas rester à la charge de ma
famille et de la société donc à l'art
fait deux enfants l'un des deux
auparavant ce qui était déjà un exploit
en tant que tel et puis elle a créée et
elle gère le seul et unique centre
d'accueil pour handicapés au maroc le
dirige elle même elle y consacre sa vie
et sa fortune
ce centre il s'appelle nord nord en
arables ça veut dire la lumière et cette
femme elle est simplement lumineuse et
leur l'endroit qu'elle dirige est à son
image
un autre exemple encore une femme dont
le nom a été très connu à une époque pas
par les plus jeunes
ici c'était une grande productrice de
cinéma qui s'appelait albina du
boisrouvray elle a produit énormément de
très grands classiques du cinéma
français et cette femme aussi un drame
dans sa vie elle était la mère d'un
garçon d'ailleurs beau comme un dieu qui
se trouve être
le compte du le pilotait l'hélicoptère
qui s'est crashé pendant le paris dakar
et dans lequel il y avait balavoine et
terry sabine évidemment la mort de ce
fils a dévasté cette femme elle a
abandonné
ça son métier de productrice elle a
vendu sa maison de production pour une
somme considérable
elle a tout investi ce qu'elle en avait
tiré dans une fondation qui a commencé
par s'intéresser aux orphelins du sida
parce que c'était l'époque où le sida
massacrait des générations entières dans
les pays
bien sûr les plus défavorisés et puis
elle a conçu progressivement un concept
nouveau qu'elle a appelé les visages et
philippe et de ses initiales de son fils
où on prend en charge enfants et
adolescents une prise en charge
absolument complète c'est-à-dire le gic
le couvert la santé l'éducation
jusqu à les amener à une insertion
professionnelle véritable donc ça
démarre bébé et ça va jusqu'à
l'insertion professionnelle voilà un
autre exemple de ce que peut faire la
philanthropie
voilà donc que des histoires formidables
je pourrais vous en citer encore plein
d'autres 1 un autre nom célèbre une eau
de nos vainqueurs viviane senna
la soeur du pilote automobile ayrton
senna qui a créé elle avait imaginé créé
avec son frère et puis c'est tuer
prématurément et donc elle a créé une
fondation qui s'occupe des enfants des
favelas brésiliennes et ça aussi c'est
quelque chose d'absolument exceptionnel
donc que des jolies histoires
donc il est facile de parler de la
philanthropie mais ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est que si je si j'aime
autant en parler c'est pas par hasard
c'est parce que je pense qu'il ya des
enjeux absolument considérable à ce
niveau là quand vous regardez l'état de
notre société
bon c'est pas difficile il suffit
d'ouvrir au journal d'allumer la télé
pour voir à quel point cette société
elle est fracturée explosé elle pose des
problèmes monstrueux il ya de plus en
plus de besoins et en face de ses
besoins
il faut voir les choses comme elles sont
il ya de moins en moins de ressources
l'état fait ce qu'il peut
on a tendance à dire l'état se désengage
s'est pas complètement vrai l'état il
fait ce qu'il peut avec ce qu'il a
je le peux vous le dire parce que je
préside d'une grande association
culturelle qui est un ballet qui
s'appelle le ballet prejlocaj qui est
basée à aix-en-provence bond qui vit
avec 47 48 % de ses recettes sous forme
de subvention à l'état les collectivités
locales ont toujours été présentes ils
se sont pas retirés mais si on veut
faire plus si on veut avoir plus de
moyens là il n'y a pas la possibilité de
pouvoir demander plus aux pouvoirs
publics et donc il faut se tourner vers
l'argent privé
il faut qu'on aille au delà de ce
clivage qui malheureusement a trop
pénaliser la vie publique en france
entre le public et le privé le public
garant de l'intérêt général et le privé
un peu douteux parfois même un peu sale
l'argent qu'elle il faut pas toucher
cette époque là est révolue c'est fini
il faut aller chercher les ressources là
où elles sont et les ressources ou sont
elles dans le privé avec deux
orientations majeures les entreprises
c'est le mécénat d'entreprise et la
philanthropie c'est le mécénat des
particuliers alors les entreprises elles
ont un jeu un rôle formidablement
important à jouer dans la société un peu
des structures et aujourd'hui où on voit
une crise disons morale extrêmement
grave dans l'école dans les syndicats
bon l'armée a disparu en tant que
service militaire dans les églises dans
les partis politiques
on voit dans les syndicats on voit bien
que la crise est présente une crise
morale l'entreprise elle garde un rôle
de responsabilité sociétale et c'est
très intéressant de voir à quel point
elle est arrivée à ceux à se
ce point l'adresse conseiller social à
partir de la responsabilité sociale de
l'entreprise la rse dont vous avez tous
entendu parler
ça c'est quelque chose qui a été imposée
par le régulateur qui imposait aux
entreprises de travailler correctement
de faire correctement leur métier en
respectant des critères de parité de
diversité de management équilibrée et
c'est l'humanité disons dans la façon
d'exercer son métier et d'éthique
à partir de là les entreprises
commencent maintenant est sous la
pression des collaborateurs et notamment
des plus jeunes collaborateurs parce
qu'il ya un véritable état d'esprit
nouveau qui est né à ce niveau-là à
s'intéresser à ce qu'elles peuvent faire
autour d'elle plus simplement en elle
responsabilité sociale de l'entreprise
mais autour d'elle responsabilité
sociétale et le mécénat est bien sûr une
façon de s'intéresser à son
environnement
le mécénat retenez qu'il est d'abord et
avant tout locale ça c'est vrai partout
dans le monde quand quelqu'un a envie
d'être mécène il va d'abord regarder
autour de lui
le monde autour de lui pour essayer de
faire de faire des choses de faire
bouger des choses autour de lui et on
voit bien que dans tous les domaines et
dans le domaine culturel
c'est particulièrement vrai bon j'ai en
tête une expérience que j'ai vécue
ici avec quelqu'un qui est aujourd'hui à
sarrebourg qui s'appelle alain pacquier
les chemins du baroque
on va la grande aventure de recherche
des musiques qui avaient été amenés par
les jésuites à l'époque du film mission
de la colonisation espagnole et
portugaise
ces musiques baroques qui ont été
retrouvés dans les tribus indiennes
d'amérique latine
bon ça c'était une aventure absolument
formidable et qui a été permise par le
mécénat donc un rôle de la de
l'entreprise de plus en plus important
et puis à côté de l'entreprise bahia
nous il ya nous il ya des citoyens quand
on regarde la société comment elle
fonctionne quand on regarde la violence
latente
on voit bien que cette notion de citoyen
elle a besoin d'être remise sacrément
sur le devant de la scène
si vous ouvrez le larousse vous allez
voir que la définition de citoyens c'est
celui qui a droit de cité
moi j'ai envie de vous dire je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut c'est le
devoir de cité c'est que chacun prenne
conscience que on peut chacun notre
place on peut et donc on doit chacun
notre place faire quelque chose pour la
société pour de nous pour l'intérêt
général pour essayer de faire bouger un
peu cette société canon sacrément besoin
dans la bonne direction et de la faire
progresser
et pour moi la philanthropie ça se
limite pas à bill gates et à des
dizaines de milliards de dollars
la philanthropie c'est une façon d'être
au monde c'est une façon d'être en
société d'interagir avec les autres de
s'intéresser avec les uns aux autres et
je vais vous raconter une petite
expérience que j'ai vécue avec une une
association qui a été créée par la
fondation rothschild qui s'appelle
l'école de la philanthropie l'école de
la fée entreprise est une expérience qui
consiste à sélectionner des classes de
cm2 donc vous voyez l'âge des gamins dix
ans il y en a une quinzaine pour le
moment ils ont commencé par la grande
région parisienne est plutôt bien sûr
dans les zones défavorisées
chacune des classes alors il faut
l'accord des maîtres et maîtresses et
directeurs et directrices d'école
chacune des classes qui a été
sélectionné va être mise en partenariat
pendant un an avec une association donc
les gamins vont vivre pendant l'année la
vie de l'association le mercredi le
week-end les vacances
donc ils vont plonger dans la vie
d'associations essayé de faire des
choses avec les bénévoles engagés dans
l'association est
ils organisent en général une fête qui a
un côté à la fois festif et puis en même
temps un peu collecte de fonds et à la
fin de l'année la fondation rothschild
organise un grand show dans un beau lieu
en général et
chaque classe a une demi-heure avec son
association pour venir raconter ce
qu'ils ont vécu et moi je vous garantis
que quand on entend ces gamins venus de
souvent d'horizon pas favorisés dit on
s'est rendu compte pendant cette année
là que c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup de sous qu'on peut pas faire
des choses pour les autres et qu'on peut
pas aider les autres moi j'ai la
conviction que ces gamins là ils seront
marqués à vie parce qu'ils ont vécu et
que l'incivisme la violence dans
laquelle on vit aujourd'hui c'est comme
ça il faut l'adresser s'étend en allant
à la racine et en acclimatant les plus
jeunes à l'idée qu'une société c'est
d'abord et avant tout du vivre ensemble
moi j'ai la conviction que le système
dans lequel nous vivons le système
libéral dans lequel nous vivons
c'est le seul possible pour une raison
très simple basique c'est le seul qui
est créateur de richesses
tous les autres se sont cassé la figure
mais ce système là le seul viable il
explosera il explosera dans la violence
il est pas foutu de mieux partager la
richesse qui a été créée et ça c'est la
responsabilité de chacun d'entre nous se
partagent cet intérêt aux autres
travaillent en commun ce travail
collectif le public et le privé les
entreprises et les particuliers c'est
comme ça qu'on arrivera à faire bouger
la société est elle en a sacrément
besoin et je trouve que ce qui se passe
ici se tait dicks quand je vois toute la
bande de bénévoles qu'il a permis qu'ils
organisaient et bien voilà pour moi ça
c'est exemplaire de ce qu'il faut faire
et donc si j'ai un message à vous
délivrer à la fin de cette présentation
s'est engagé vous et si vous ne savez
pas comment le faire et bien il ya des
institutions qui sont faites pour ça
admical par exemple qui est la grande
institution qui s'occupe de mécénat elle
a un très beau site qui s'appelle
admical point org
allez voir le portail du mécénat et vous
y trouverez tout ce que vous étiez au
voulu savoir sur la philanthropie et le
mécénat et vous avez jamais osé demander
faite le merci